well it's been a very tough two years
for so many businesses and staffing
issues just aren't getting any better
for small business owners in the valley
that's right and the issues have been
going on long enough now some places are
forced to close their doors joe muller
joins us near stephanie street and
horizon ridge with one man's story joe
well the owner of me peru here in
henderson says after struggling for
months he'll have to close up his
restaurant here for good that means that
open sign will not turn back on in a few
weeks he and other business owners say
they did not think it would be this hard
to find help
i mean the last six months have been
really tough it's a decision no
restaurant owner wants to make after 14
years we decide to
close raymie mosca says he can't find
enough staff to keep the doors open at
me peru it's hard
we did our best we put our best effort
very challenging for a small business
trying to hire people right now he says
other companies are paying higher wages
and offering benefits something he can't
compete with just finding staff was very
very hard victoria martinez owns sunset
montessori school she is also having a
hard time maybe people save money and
are not ready to go back to work others
are having a change of heart like i've
done this my whole life maybe i want to
try something different unlv economic
professor stephen miller says it is a
changing economy i think we're seeing
restructuring in the labor market he
says smaller businesses are not able to
keep up with what some other businesses
are offering it's not a problem if you
have the necessary profit margin that
allows you to
to offer a few more benefits or to pay a
higher wage
that's what's happening mosca says he
hopes to reopen one day meanwhile his
customers were saddened to hear the news
pretty sad to see our local businesses
struggling through the pandemic
so yeah we'll enjoy this last meal
now back out here live mosca says he'll
try and stay open for a few more weeks
but he does plan to close for good right
before christmas reporting live in
henderson this evening joe mohler live
local now